this is the scarred and battered mining
town of volidar
it's held by Ukraine but is being
attacked continuously by Russian forces
we entered with a military escort
as it came under Fire again
the soldiers taking us towards Frontline
positions warn us to space out and not
hang around we need to move fast over
this bit is the constant threat of an
artillery strike
it is a gut churning zigzag across the
Broken Ground
while taking cover there are moments of
quiet
before another shell whistle through the
sky
this place has been absolutely
devastated by the fighting
every apartment block has had the
windows blown out there are shell
craters all around us
and there's still plenty of incoming
fire as well
about 15 000 people lived here until it
was smashed by War only a handful
remained there are no services and they
collect rainwater from drain pipes to
survive always staying close to cover
it is
watch interview
perhaps nothing sums up the insanity of
the war more than this the wholesale
destruction of people's lives and
possessions
about two kilometers of enemies then
about two kilometers the town we're told
is strategically important as Ukrainian
forces can Target Russian supply lines
it's why moscow's forces are desperate
to capture it
foreign yeah
inside a bunker one of the commanders
has just coordinated a counter-attack he
shows us a panorama of the town
and the body of a dead Russian Commando
on a live stream beamed from a drone
is
foreign
we were taken to another position near
the town this time with a different
Brigade a message comes through that
Russian troops are on the move
since the start of the kremlin's new
offensive they've been very active along
the line of contact
the soldiers in the trenches respond
by laying down an arc of Fire
the razor wire in front of them is a
last defense against Russia's human wave
assaults
the trenches in this part of the front
extend for miles and miles now the team
here their job is to spot for any
movement the Russians are only a couple
of kilometers away and they also have a
Russian radio
and they're able to listen in to their
Communications
the soldiers here say they can defend
their positions they are renewed to this
hell
but Russia is a powerful enemy and
doesn't seem to care how many men it
pushes forwards
Alex Rossi Sky News in eastern Ukraine